[Music]
hello everybody my name is marbl and
welcome to to the Moon you will not
believe how much this particular game
has been requested over the past year
and I don't know why I've been waiting
so long to play it but I decided that
I'm going to dedicate myself to making a
full very very very thorough playthrough
of this game not that there's like all
that much secret stuff to it but I'm
going to dedicate myself to it because a
lot of people have been really demanding
it it's supposed to have a beautiful
story it's an RPG Adventure game made in
RPG Maker I believe but this game came
out about 2 3 years ago and it like blew
people's minds at how fantastic the
story was or how beautiful it was I
don't know anything about it in all
honesty I've somehow magically not had
anything spoiled for me I just had
people that inundated like endless
endless asking for this game to be
played by me me so I'm going to play it
we're going to see it we're going to
have a real good Adventure uh this isn't
a Indie this isn't an RPG horror game by
the way this is just a pure and simple
Adventure RPG with one hell of a story
you're so I've heard so let's see let's
see I can't move cuz I'm listening to
someone play the piano I'm
assuming okay someone got in a bit of an
accident oh they're okay then
nice jump there
lady where were you looking
Neil well excuse me for heroically
evading that squirrel coming out of
nowhere yes Save the squirrel
indefinitely you ran over it anyways
oh oh you ran over it and hit the tree
look don't worry it's a company car are
you kidding me the boss is going to kill
us H well we'll just to say I was saving
a puppy he likes puppies right he's more
of a cat
person why does the world have to be so
complicated fine whatever furball he
fancies crisis
averted good go write that on your Port
later let's grab the equipment from the
car and move already okay left click an
object to interact with it received
equipment got the sucker let's roll
right click to toggle menu or cancel oh
so it's all play by the mouse yes I
guess I can go ahead and save now all
right so ah I see okay so I need to go
up this way or up that way the sign of
the house points the other way Dingus oh
how kind of it to exist is that what it
said hang on whan household ahead
putting a sign up when they live in the
middle of nowhere is like asking to be
robbed well good hey wait don't forget
the car just wanted to see if you'd
remembered
oh how thoughtful of you well good okay
so we're going up to this house where
I'm assuming the kids were playing piano
what a studious and good thing to do who
put a boulder here maybe it's their
security system cucumbers we don't have
time for this fluff nice sensoring let's
try pushing it out of the way maybe we
could find a tree bans to jack it with
wait or we could just call it a night
and blame it on
that uh aboard Mission and go home now
uh finding a branch for leverage sounds
like the smarter idea a branch will do
oh so now I'm playing the lady doctor
receive tree branch huh I'm going to
push this is going to roll down on top
of us and we're all going to die game
over all right this better
work it just what what was that I I
don't
even it deflated it's some kind of
airball oh okay they didn't even try I
guess I could have pushed it by hand
then oh well my bad
right right right right right right
right also I've been told that the music
in this game is really good and I can
already tell that that's true judging by
what my ears are being assaulted
by okay so we're going up towards the
house I hope you guys can see my mouse
cuz that would be kind of important in
this game I don't know if it's recording
the mouse cursor though if it's not I'll
fix it in the next episode that you can
see I mean it's not terribly important
just shows you where I'm going but you
can see where I'm going judging by my
character Ma they're
here it's a nice house in the middle of
nowhere not a bad not a bad place to
retire at
huh I could do better I'm a doctor I'm I
make six figure salaries night shifts
love him or hate him you know the answer
you stupid
owl she's very insulting it's probably
going to be another all nighter you know
I know also has a very deep voice and I
doubt they'd have any coffee shut
up knock knock knock in the ocean waves
will sing lullab not through your
blathering they
won't and your eyelids will oh hello
don't forget the equipment oh GE
hot gosh why you can't be so mean I
don't get paid enough for this well you
get paid enough to complain about it
apparently you can buy a bigger house
than this so whoopy Doo Mr Rich doctor
man act one I never told anyone but I've
always thought they were
lighthouses was that the name of the ACT
wow is that the
tagline so we got a bit of a a silly
happy go-lucky intro Dr wats and Dr
Roslin I
presume
rosalene thanks for coming on such short
notice that's okay I tend to be bad at
predicting deaths as well what are you
the patient's daughter oh no I'm just
his caretaker guy's bedside manner needs
some work and these are my children
Sarah and Tommy it's not exactly a 9
to-5 job so Johnny lets us live here I
suppose this Johnny is our man
Johnny listen if it's a kid we're
dealing with I don't think we're the
ones you want no no no he he just
prefers to be called
[Music]
that he's upstairs right now with his
medical doctor come with
me you got it I've already forgotten
your name Sarah Sally come on grab the
case and let's go when my back breaks
one day I'll sue you with the insurance
claim all right got it hell
all right let's head upstairs before I
drop this a there are other arrows
leading down can I go there
too the patient is waiting upstairs
better not waste time okay no exploring
for now go upstairs absolutely yes I
agree I concur doctor okay they're gone
whoever gets there first gets to play
The Melody wow these kids love piano
that's cool though could to have a hobby
no fear you push me did not whatever you
get the boring two notes
anyway oh it's beautiful oh I got to
learn piano someday I I played trumpet
in high school for a long time so I know
music I know how to read it but God I I
need to learn how to play I just don't
have the spare time it's like playing
piano learning uh finishing up learning
guitar and then learning to sing that's
all like on my plate at the moment but
God I'm so busy playing video games you
know it's is the
worst those kids are pretty good for
their age hey you're the one who said
there was no time to waste and
incidentally I'm the one who's carrying
the weight of a small
meteoroid yeah yeah come
on okay wait where am I supposed to go
it's like nothing here what oh there was
a secret door oh okay I got
you he's unresponsive at this point but
it looks by the looks of things he's
still consciously hanging on
it's hard to say how long you'll have
but I would hurry okay what are we doing
exactly ready to set up look around
first gee you know I think I'd like to
carry this excruciatingly heavy object
around some more thanks for asking
though thanks for putting up with it I
have to explore your house see all the
Wonders is there a shiny
there uh ohoo this is a nice house oh
how lovely it is okay I don't know if
there's going to be any secret things
that I need but something here a
selection of readings from medical
journals okay nothing important there uh
is there anything down there that I
need are those important the paintings
should I remember
those no painting of a woman holding
something yellow and blue I feel like I
should remember these a painting of a
lighthouse by Cliffside woman yellow and
blue an animal of some
sort painting a casual painting of three
people so Lighthouse y yellow and blue
animal three people I'll try to remember
but I can't promise anything maybe you
guys will be able to help me out repeat
that Mantra down in the comments below
make this turn into a real cult
Lighthouse yellow and blue animal three
people okay so I looked around first
people acting casually of course a lot
of people worked on this you know some
people think of these RPG Maker games as
just like casual games that people make
on their own but there's some people
that go a serious length to make it good
are you sure a common household power
outlet is sufficient no worries we're
the
experts kachunk uh-oh oh
crap oh there we go standard procedures
just keeping you on your
toes whoa goodness gravy that looks
Fancy no wonder who it's so heavy it's
very technological how's he doing not so
well if I were to say he's got just a
day or two left that's plenty of
time so you two can grant him any wish
huh to try at least but we always
succeed because we're awesome I think
that guy actually is me so what's the
wish the moon that's a pretty tall order
the
Moon the Moon he wants to go to the
Moon the Gyer just keeps on getting the
Geyers just keep on getting crazier huh
so can you do
it it depends she meant to say yes why
don't you tell us about our client
here that I don't really know
much Johnny's an odd man through the two
years that I've worked here he rarely
spoke he worked as a Craftsman for most
of his life and his wife passed away 2
years
ago I don't really know many details I
would have known more if I were as a
paper boy for petza
sake shush just do your
thing well I suppose if you look around
the house you may find some more info I
suppose Johnny wouldn't mind since he
signed for you
to so be
it all right then all right which one of
us plays
Detective uh Dr rosalin I like her
better anyway thanks for the offer but
I'm busy leaving a butt print in this
chair right do continue Tommy and Sarah
can chill you around they're probably at
the piano downstairs okay then so I
already know Lighthouse woman yellow and
blue animal three people that's what I
know wait come back for a second I have
something for you all right then geez
doctor could told me sooner before I
walked agonizingly slow here take this
receive remote patient monitor that'll
keep you updated on Johnny's status
thanks I was just going to ask for it
Johnny's heart monitor is now activated
in the menu okay cool so that's good
right I think is that good okay what was
that say anyway senior memory traversal
agent Sigman Corp ah named after Sigman
Freud of course okay it
is apparently it's 11: doesn't matter
what minute it is it's 11: kids you're
playing beautifully but I think I'm on a
time crunch here and I need to get a
tour what you want show me around the
house Sarah and Tommy right your mother
said to ask you two to show me around
the house okay maybe we will but maybe
we
won't I think we just need a little
convincing that's all what do you think
Tommy
yeah uh what would you like we want1
trillion
do or the candy cane mom hides from us
either one yeah or that huh there's a
giant candy cane on top of the high
shelf we can't reach it's in the kitchen
M put it there to save us when we do
chores get it for us and we'll give you
a tour through the house what you
say well no cut the crap and help that
sounds more like this character we're
short on time now but if you just show
me around then Dr Watts will pay for
however many candy canes you want later
yes yes really like even if I ask for 10
you know a trillion why ask for 10 or 12
or a trillion no more than five they're
bad calories that's still better than
one okay deal then well that was easy
fine by me good old doct Roslin
exploiting the work of young children
okay where do we start I know there's
this funny room in the basement I don't
like that funny room what do you mean by
funny room you'll
see it's
weird okay kind of disturbed we need to
get the keys though the old man HD it
inside a book in the study okay where's
the study is this a study over here or
is that the study over to the left study
this looks like studyes this is the book
room the key to the funny room is in the
thickest book on the upper shelf if you
say so still not entirely sure why we're
doing all this why do I need a door of
the house dusk light the tale of a girl
fell in love with a zombie who emitted
the smell of daisies when showered with
gentle sunlight I believe it turn that
into a movie uh maybe another year
received a room key he chose his hiding
spot well no one would dare open that
dastard book see Emperor's New Clothes
ah oh the colors the colors of that
beautiful fabric I have never seen
anything like it in my life they all
tried to conceal their disappointment in
not being able to see the clothes a
child however who had no important role
and could only see things as his eyes
showed them to him went up to the
carriage but he hasn't got anything on
the child said don't talk nonsense his
father reprimanded but the boy's remark
which has been heard by the bystander
was repeated over and over so what does
that mean so he wasn't actually wearing
anything or is that from something that
I should know already if that's a
reference please let me know in the
comments below okay so I got the key to
the basement now we can open the funny
room in the basement now I'm sure you'll
like it down
there we play hideand-seek in here turn
on the light before you trip over
something Okie dookie then chest is
locked I hear a weird gurgle Dusty pile
of anamorphs books sit here I loved
anamorphs oh man I read anamorphs when I
was a kid all the time open the door
with a room key all right who's in here
whoa It's like a cave in
here whoa okay someone told me this
wasn't an RPG horror game what the hell
is going on here a rabbit folded out of
paper a broken music box a stuffed toy
plat okay it looks adorable enough to
annoy might comeing handy oh it po
it it
up take it okay then that was weird why
why why am I in here if if you guys just
tricked me into playing this game cuz it
was actually a horror game oh my
goodness did you see it what what do you
two know about all those rabbits why so
menacing nothing the old man didn't want
anyone to go inside so we never told him
there's more of them actually where
inside the abandoned Lighthouse just
beneath this Cliff want to go see I got
the keys you aren't supposed to go in
there either are
[Music]
you that's how I imagine Sarah laughs
remind me to never take you to Neil's
house so you want to go see the
lighthouse sure well it's rather cold
outside
but yeah go to the lighthouse of course
you know what fine maybe it'll tell me
about those rabbits let's go check that
old lighthouse out cuz goodness gracious
this old man is creepy is there
something oh there was
something okay let me actually hang on
So the patient's doing fine right let me
just there was something down there that
I wanted to check also get out of my way
little kid you don't know who you're
dealing with I'm Dr
Roslin I got to check out more stuff
about this house because I'm having I
have a feeling that exploration is going
to be a very important part of this game
cabinet is filled with Dusty books
cabinet is filled with unused China
chest is locked God damn it it's just
another unlocked chest okay so I don't
need to be here whoa walking's a little
funky taking me a little getting used to
I wouldn't mind actually having the wac
controls but hey it's all right I'll get
used to
it all right let's go to this
Lighthouse oh now I'm fast okay I'm only
fast when I'm outside cuz no running in
the house if you know what I mean okay
what's going on with this Lighthouse and
why does this old man have a lighthouse
there it
is yep we need to head south to the
street and take another path to get down
to it though yeah I forgot my parachute
okay so I got to go all the way back
down to the street this better be worth
it also why was that bird following me
all right let's go hope you don't have
any more inflatable rocks blocking my
way all right there's a mystery here
hello squirrels sorry I killed your
friend oh no my novelty beach ball
someone broke it ah it was stupid anyway
but but it's the bestest novelty beach
ball I've ever had oh could have been so
cruel Dr Watts could have been uh look
I'll buy you another one no don't do it
you will sure but we kind of need to get
going now oh man I should have pushed it
out of the way that probably changed the
entire game Chang just because of that
one action the damn beach ball it's
smoking who's the dummy that crash the
car not me it's pretty dark out aren't
you kids scared of course not we role
play it away what Tommy's a super
powerful knight and I'm a mighty
magician that was a real what on my
behalf by the way yeah we destroy all
evil oh that's a that's nice do you role
play too I uh no she's not cool enough
to do it hey I could if I wanted to I'm
a doctor just you children watch I'm a
space ninja from the planet zargon I can
conquer all evil in these Woods what the
hell oh a squirel you kids talk funny
hello oh no it's a terrible squirrel
gone
what
what don't worry children I'll protect
[Music]
you oh boy really
okay okay armag get in shoe go
Sho oh God yes loudest you're uh time is
at an end squirrel
[Music]
gun stop it or we'll tell you Ma Ma you
animal abuse oh
yeah she'll call the cops on you what I
was just I was wasn't going to didn't
you say you like role
playing oh oh
no that was like awesome you should be
ashamed of
yourself let's name it Teddy okay let's
just forget this happened nobody say
anything bird you trying to get my
attention birdie
birdie birdie bird okay it's just
confused about life I guess so let's go
to this Lighthouse before anything else
that was charming and adorable I'm
pretty sure Dr Watts would never have
this much
fun okay maybe it would who
knows it does seem weird that Dr rosin
have to deal with all these kids she
seemed like the total
badass ooh here we
go is there a Mysteries to be unsolved
here what is this in memory of of river
e Wilds was that his
wife was she John's wife that's what I
asked don't know come on the light out
right there come on all right fine you
impatient kids my patient's only dying
and all that it got red and ominous in
here
so where are all these paper rabbits you
told me
B there they are creepy ass rabbits this
is it
a multicolored paper rabbit hey this
wasn't here when we came last week oh
yeah Johnny must have came here before
he fell ill again is the only one with
two colors huh you know these things
actually look pretty hard to fold kind
of an odd hobby
though it's my
phone it's
watts is everything
ready all right I'll be right right
there why do you have a creepy ringtone
cuz it scares the monsters away come on
let's head back received paper rabbit
why did I take
it all right then I guess we're
continuing
forward by the way if you couldn't tell
these are going to be 30-minute episodes
hooray all right whoa what's on the old
guy's face oh why don't you be late by
another half hour not like we got a
dying client or anything I got caught up
in something I got caught up in
something too it's called a job get off
your high horse I'm late just this one
time and you milk it at least tell me
we're good to go of course we are
because I'm competent Dr Watt is the
biggest douche your helmet's on the
couch Chop Chop okie dokie then initiate
should I initiate not yet hang on let me
talk to these guys first go on I'll
watch over his physical conditions
through the
procedure by the way I'm curious how
does does it work do you just write him
another life like a a novel I want to
hear about this no we can't just make up
new memories out of thin air then how do
you do it not us the machine does most
of it naturally since we aren't paid
enough to get our hands dirty in a
nutshell we simply travel through his
memories to as early as possible when we
do we would then transfer his registered
desire of going to the moon to the
Reconstruction of the world and himself
in an early State and with the help of a
Wiki of data and his own the machine
would then simulate a rerun except this
time he'll have the motivation of this
registered Desire with him all his life
so you'd be depending on him fulfilling
his own Wish by Simply Having the desire
to do so how could that be everyone has
ambition for most things but most don't
accomplish them it's because in the real
world Ambitions fluctuate and
fade people start things with a passion
but eventually they lose that initial
drive and slow down but imagine if you
locked onto that initial push through
your entire life never wavering
it's more powerful than it seems that
being said no ambition is going to help
a dead man we better go get started oh
of course sorry all right then wait hang
on I need to save before I do this let
us save I guess I'll just start cycling
through them there's only three so God
this game got real we're going to live
this guy's whole life again in just two
days cuz that's how long he has left to
live we're going to Inception this
let's go
wow yeah that is literally on his face
what in the
world god I think I'm ready to have my
mind blown in half whoa it doesn't
necessarily look
[Music]
good who this should be the last
accessible
memory to say dis aable speech for all
except Johnny done let's get
him at any time you can view your
position in time by moving the mouse
towards the top of the screen what holy
crap oh my goodness that's so awesome
this is
nuts so this is the last accessible
memory so this is when uh oh God that's
why everything is in like a days and so
like faded out and blurry oh my God
that's so
cool for
River what kind of song is this is this
two notes repeated over and over again
hey two notse repeated can be very
powerful so where is Johnny where's
Johnny boy looks like the rest of the
world is kind of torn off some of the
memory fragments aren't
there what time is it receive note
clock okay note clock the clock in
Johnny's House never
tick okay is that
important wait is there something else
here that I
need
no
okay I think we're good I think we're
good okay let's carry
on oh man this is weird so
cool what's happening what's happening
uh-oh who's
this uh-oh
is that his wife or is that his
[Music]
caretaker
Johnny what a pleasant surprise we don't
get many visitors around
here my name is Dr Eva rosalin and this
is Dr Von Matterhorn Dr Lorenzo Von
matorn sick How I Met Your Mother
reference though
okay Dr Neil Watts that's awesome how I
made your mother reference in here
that's amazing are you familiar with the
Sigman agency of Life generation oh are
you too from the agency how convenient
I've just been thinking of calling you
Lily get us some tea
please
Lily actually you've already called
us oh that would be disturbing to a man
old
man
we're here to fulfill our contract from
the relative future what the hell
careful there if you slip off the cliff
we're going to have to reload this
memory watch it Neil show some respect
eh it's just a program you know I know
but this is his last accessible memory
and we need its cooperation worst comes
the worst we can just reboot it why
would you waste time like that
you you're here to take take me to the
Moon aren't
you yes
John I suppose I had a good
run not good enough it
seems so can you do
it can you take me to the
Moon we can but you might be able to why
do you want to go there
I don't
[Music]
know it's fine you can tell us it's
essential for helping us to get you to
go there do you want the fame the money
you've got to have a
motive I'm sorry but I really don't
know I just
do I can already tell that this is going
to be a pain in the
ass nevertheless Johnny here's what
we'll
do we need to go to your childhood but
is too distant to do so in one memory
hop thus we will need to Traverse
through your memories in gradual
backwards leaps which you've given us
the permission to do in the relative
future once we lay down the waypoints in
your childhood memories for direct
access we will return here that's when
you'll need to help us influence your
childhood you to become an astronaut or
to get on a giant catapult the point is
you'll need to have more to say than
just I don't know as long as you can
take me to the Moon I will cooperate in
any way possible
[Music]
good now in order to LEAP to a memory we
need an item that is of importance to
you do you have a momento of some sort
to get us started is this like momento
the
movie hey it's the multicol rabbit
that'll
do well shall we ladies
first are we about to time Jump no the
moon we'll need to prepare this momento
first wait hang on let me see this the
Moon is Johnny's memory the moon in
Johnny's memory is full okay so that's
something important I should remember
right let me
save God there's so much stuff here
actually I'm all out of time for this
episode holy crap this is amazing like
this story is so engrossed me it's weird
like to play a game that has like a
seriously good story is like one of my
favorite things I love to get involved
in so either way I will end this episode
here let me know what you think of this
game in the description below please I
want to hear all the words about it let
me know thank you all so much for
watching Click The annotation for more
videos that I've done check out more RPG
games that I played most of them have
been horror down in the description
below but there's also off which was an
incredibly weird Journey that you should
definitely try thanks again everyone and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye it was weird seeing all
the Vlogs that I've done in the past and
um it may
it I I had like this crashing Revelation
to do a more relaxed and a better
commentary let's play than I've done in
the past because I feel very strongly
about these indie games